i want to talk to you about something
you posted about the two little girls
that the sesame street character waved
off did you see that ridiculous apology
they had all i can think about is the
mps sesame street has been a huge part
of my bring up like of of growing me of
teaching me of learning about so many
the abcs to who i am
the how important your neighborhood is
there's so many
things that make it so incredibly
important so when i saw this and it was
an extension of what i grew up learning
and loving about sesame street and
sesame place
i don't know what place this is
that i saw and it made a
beautiful two beautiful little girls
feel like they were just
not there and when you go and you shake
hands with another girl that's not her
complexion or race
i would live it and i know me personally
i would have burned the place down i
said it before and i really mean it and
i really mean what i said about sesame
street i love sesame street
i don't know what sesame place is but i
know that that was unacceptable yeah
yeah and i i wasn't trying to give it
any more attention i really wasn't but
those little girls
they deserve and they deserve an apology
exactly all right i know you've heard
beyonce's album how is it
hi i don't know what you're talking
about how's that out oh
i'm pregnant
come on now
okay last question
her album comes out then it seems like
y'all would go into a cycle
it's right the time is right now the
kids are old enough where y'all can take
them on tour oh my god everything is
perfect oh my gosh
i saw usher two days ago
and he was incredible in vegas isn't he
incredible no no it's so great i'm going
back this man sings live the whole way
through and does not break and
he's he's honestly the king of rv
she is i mean i mean who are the queens
who are the queens
there are several oh
come on
i know you keep saying this time with
kevin yeah you would be at the
rehearsals
just know that okay just chill you would
be at the rehearsals we trust you we
love you you would have that moment okay
ain't nothing happening
don't y'all believe that cause they'll
something will drop at midnight there'll
be a song kelly will be on the song
something will happen
[Music]